[Music]
thomas
[Music]
you seem particularly triggered right
now can you tell me what happened
i've had dreams that weren't just dreams
am i crazy
we don't use that word in here
[Music]
hi
[Music]
have we met
[Music]
one pill makes you larger and
one pill makes you small
and the ones that
mother gives you
don't do
anything
[Music]
time to fly
[Music]
[Music]
the only thing that matters to you is
still here i know it's why you're still
fighting
and why you will never give up
you don't know me
no
logics
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
see
[Applause]
after all these years to be going back
to where it all started
back to the matrix
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
july 20th
1969.
that's one small step for
[Music]
in school you were taught that apollo 11
lost contact with the world for two
minutes
[Music]
not true
they found something on that day
that they kept him for 50 years
and now
it's too late to stop
in breaking news the governor has just
ordered the mass evacuation of the
entire west coast
moving to higher ground it's the only
possible chance of surviving
stay away my brothers and sisters
stay away
this planet
has suffered five extinctions
this
is going to be the sixth
are we dead
you know we are just inside the moon
that might be the greatest sentence
anyone's ever said
[Music]
[Music]
i remember revelations
and i looked
as he opened the sixth seal
there was a great earthquake
judgment day
raise a call i'm calling about what
happened to new york
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
oh my god
what is happening here
my grandfather was a ghostbuster
something was coming and he knew it
i think we opened the gates of hell
hey have you missed us
[Applause]
[Music]
i still can't believe it are you gonna
fall in love with a new little person
again
just breathe
i'm gonna hang down from three
and on three
and two and one
[Music]
i can't lie to my family anymore
[Music]
the second you tell your wife that you
are dying
your opportunity to do this is gone
[Music]
you want to go say hi
[Music]
[Music]
invited
so he has everything even the memories
you store deep in your subconscious
do this with us and let life go on for
your family a clean swab
what's going on
can't figure out what the right thing is
here
i thought i had more time i guess
you have an opportunity here i'm not
done i didn't say he could you're dying
i feel like i've fallen in love with it
for the first time again
you don't like this you think i like
this
being told i'm not me because you're not
me
you are not
i love you cam antenna
[Music]
go go
flight recorders are on t minus five
four
three
two
one
zero
[Applause]
this is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
to infinity
and
oh look at this this is a good one some
suggest that parker's powers include the
male spider's ability to hypnotize
females stop come on yes my spider lord
can we just like stay up here all day it
is so crazy down there
right folks spiderman is in fact peter
parker listen i did not kill mysterio
the drones did the drones that are yours
does any part of you feel relieved about
all this what do you mean
now that everybody knows you don't
really have to hide or lie to people for
the record i never wanted to lie to you
and how do you tell someone that you're
spiderman
now everybody knows
but this isn't about me this is hurting
a lot of people
i've just been thinking about how to fix
all of this
so peter
why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry to
bother you sir please be safe to have
the universe together i think we're
beyond you calling me sir okay stephen
that feels weird but i'll allow it
when mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up
i was wondering if maybe you could make
it so that he never did
strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
fine
i won't
the entire world is about to forget that
peter parker is spider-man wait everyone
can't some people still know that's not
how the spell works
so mj is going to forget about
everything we've ever been through stop
tampering with the smell oh my god ned
he's my best friend my aunt may should
really stop talking
what just happened
we tampered with the stability of space
time
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly little
the problem is you trying to live two
different lives
the longer you do it the more dangerous
it becomes
be careful what you wish for parker
hello peter
[Music]
hello
what's your name
what the hell happened here
the umbrella corporation's been
experimenting on this town since we were
kids
people are getting sick
we have to stop umbrella show me your
hands
the world needs to know what's really
going on
get
out of this town
resident evil welcome to raccoon city
rated r exclusively in movie theaters
november 24th
[Music]
thomas ernest mother
ex-cop
convicted of murder in a burglary gone
wrong
apex is quite simple
their hunters
you are the prey
what's the price if i kill all the
hunters
win and i can guarantee your freedom
[Music]
my good hunter
welcome find me a real challenge
who the hell is that
do we get a refund if we kill this guy
within an hour
you're good kid i'm better than good i'm
bacon and eggs on sunday morning
malone has defied death more times than
those nearly seers
simply put
the universe just can't seem to kill him
men like that never should have come to
a place like this
let's remind malone who is the hunter
and who is the prey
i win that's all i do
that won't be happening
bring me the head of thomas malone
you're only logical choices to beg
beg me to let you live
this ain't that kind of fight even
better
please
hit us up
[Music]
stay still
get out of here
[Music]
fear is a tool
when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
it's a warning
[Music]
i've been driving to reach you
god
this is about a king
and rivers to match
i can take care of myself
if this continues it won't be long
before you've nothing left
i don't care what happens to me it's
only going to get worse for you
oh take it easy sweetheart
hear everything they say
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there
i'm vengeance
what's black
and blue
and dead all over
i got you
[Music]
do you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease from here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run
do it now
you've been missing for two
months you're a stranger then you were
found on a container ship that washed up
off a long island
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked not exactly i have
increased strength and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of him
he wants to hunt
half the city wants to kill you
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
the other half wants to control you hey
dr mike you and i should stay in touch
not doing anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy
it who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
[Music]
tell me something
[Music]
you can go
anywhere you want right
any timeline
and the universe
why do you want to stay
and fight to save this one
you change the future
and you change the path
are you in
oh
it takes more than guns to kill a man
you think i'm your enemy
i am your enemy
but your enemy will be gone when you
kill me
your brother is still in prison
your twin brother was an anarchist
my brother was a revolutionary
where is he
is my brother
he will last 10 minutes in the street
knowing what he knows
this
is a battleground
who's the contact
goodbye tell me so when is this gonna
happen it has happening for a thousand
years
we had a deal
your brother can expose everything
i have done what is mine to do
the world is watching what happens here
it's on
is he here now i would light myself on
fire
how come no one is hiding themselves on
fire
where's my brother
[Music]
[Music]
you